AHEAD OF THE MIDTERM ELECTIONS,
WE WILL TALK LIVE WITH
PRESIDENTIAL CONSULAR
KELLYANNE CONWAY IN A MOMENT.
FIRST, MAJOR DEVELOPMENT IN THE
CONTROVERSY OVER THE SECURITY
CLEARANCE FOR THE PRESIDENT'S
SON IN LAW WHO IS ALSO ONE OF
HIS TOP ADVISORS.
CHIEF WHITE HOUSE CORRESPONDENT
JOHN ROBERTS JOINS ME.
THE LATEST INFORMATION ABOUT
ACCESS FOR JARED KUSHNER.
>> CHIEF OF STAFF JOHN KELLY
CHANGED THE RULES REGARDING
SECURITY CLEARANCES IN THE WAKE
OF THE ROB PORTER SCANDAL.
LAST FRIDAY, A SELF-IMPOSED
DEADLINE BY KELLY, A NUMBER OF
STAFFERS HAD THEIR SECURITY
CLEARANCE IS INCLUDING JARED
KUSHNER.
THE INVESTIGATION INTO HIS
SECURITY CLEARANCE STILL NOT
COMPLETED, FIRST SON-IN-LAW
JARED KUSHNER HAD HIS CLEARANCE
DOWNGRADED.
WHILE KUSHNER CAN VIEW SOME
CLASSIFIED INFORMATION, HE
CANNOT LONGER SEE THE MOST
SENSITIVE ITEMS, LIKE THE
PRESIDENT'S DAILY BRIEF.
ASKED ABOUT THE DOWNGRADE,
PRESIDENT TRUMP WOULDN'T ANSWER.
LAST WEEK, THE PRESIDENT SAID HE
WOULD LEAVE IT TO HIS CHIEF OF
STAFF TO DECIDE WHAT TO DO ABOUT
KUSHNER'S SECURITY CLEARANCE.
>> THAT WILL BE AFTER
GENERAL KELLY.
GENERAL KELLY RESPECTS JARED A
LOT AND WILL MAKE THE CALL.
>> THE DOWNGRADE IS NOT EXPECTED
TO AFFECT THE WORK ON POLICY IN
THE MIDDLE EAST PEACE PROCESS.
A SPOKESPERSON FOR KUSHNER
SAYING "MR. KUSHNER HAS DONE
MORE THAN WHAT IS EXPECTED OF
HIM IN THIS PROCESS.
THOSE INVOLVED HAVE CONFIRMED
THERE ARE DOZENS OF PEOPLE AT
MR. KUSHNER'S LEVEL WHOSE
PROCESS IS DELAYED.
NO CONCERNS WERE RAISED ABOUT
MR. KUSHNER'S APPLICATION."
DEPUTY ATTORNEY GENERAL ROD
ROSENSTEIN INFORMED THE
WHITE HOUSE THREE WEEKS AGO THAT
THERE WERE STILL A NUMBER OF
ITEMS IN KUSHNER'S FILE THAT
REQUIRE FURTHER INVESTIGATION.
NOT KNOWN WHEN THE PROCESS WILL
BE COMPLETED OR WHETHER KUSHNER
WILL RECEIVE HIS FULL SECURITY
CLEARANCE.
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
WEIGHED IN ON PRESIDENT TRUMP'S
REQUEST TO BAN SO-CALLED
BUMP STOCKS USED LAST OCTOBER BY
THE LAS VEGAS SHOOTER.
JEFF SESSIONS SAYING HE BELIEVES
IT CAN BE DONE WITHOUT GOING
THROUGH CONGRESS.
>> OUR TOP PEOPLE IN THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE HAVE
BELIEVED FOR SOME TIME THAT
THROUGH REGULATORY PROCESS WE
CANNOT ALLOW THE BUMP STOCK TO
CONVERT A WEAPON FROM
SEMIAUTOMATIC TO FULLY
AUTOMATIC.
>> ON THE BROADER ISSUE OF GUN
SAFETY AND SCHOOL SHOOTINGS, THE
WHITE HOUSE TODAY SAID IT WILL
HAVE SOME POLICY PROPOSALS TO
ANNOUNCE LATER THIS WEEK.
ONE QUESTION, WHILE THE
PRESIDENT MAKE GOOD ON HIS
PLEDGE TO RAISE THE MINIMUM AGE
TO BUY A RIFLE OR SHOTGUN TO 21?
TO DO IT, HE WOULD HAVE TO GO UP
AGAINST THE NRA WHICH IS
STRIDENTLY OPPOSED TO THE IDEA.
>> THE PRESIDENT SAID YESTERDAY
SOMETIMES YOU HAVE TO FIGHT
THEM.
IS HE WILLING TO TAKE ON THE NRA
IS HE WILLING TO TAKE ON THE NR
NRA?
THIS IDEA OF RAISING THE MINIMUM
AGE.
>> THE PRESIDENT STILL SUPPORTS
RAISING THE AGE LIMIT TO 21 FOR
THE PURCHASE OF CERTAIN
FIREARMS.
WE ARE MEETING WITH BIPARTISAN
MEMBERS OF CONGRESS TOMORROW.
DISCUSSION.
HE KNOWS EVERYBODY DOESN'T
NECESSARILY AGREE.
>> OTHER NEWS OF THE WHITE HOUSE
THAT HAPPENED TODAY.
PRESIDENT TRUMP NAMED HIS 2020
CAMPAIGN MANAGER, BRAD PARSCALE.
HE WILL ALSO LIAISE WITH THE
CONGRESSIONAL RACES BETWEEN NOW
AND NOVEMBER, TRYING TO HOLD ON
TO THE HOUSE AND SENATE IN THE
MIDTERM ELECTIONS.
THE PRESIDENT ANNOUNCING TODAY
HE CUT A DEAL FOR TWO NEW
AIR FORCE ONE AIRCRAFT WITH
BOEING.
$3.9 BILLION DEAL.